think of a word that you would like a
rap about and then we're just going to
throw them in one at a time and i'll rap
carrot yes the first word from your
brain so
strange presumably because nothing
rhymes with all range that's the color
never bother yeah i get it a lot i got
the green fluffy top maybe like i'm
carrot top doing all the physical
comedy and a julienne i shave my carrot
tiny ribbons again and again
get a little cuisinart that's a food
mixer chop it up no risk in my fingers
addicted to getting all the vitamin a
what's the words that you say coming
over here hip parade
get this one a lot got a pen with a drop
i'm a british guy talking [ __ ] that
poppy [ __ ] like a little red flower on
the end of your penis
that's a poppy [ __ ] it's obscene this
bringing it up
yeah you know what you're chosen take
the poppy pollen i'll be turning it to
opium
like i'm in afghanistan what's my man
gonna give
yeah oh you know i'm in a siege got a
little trebuchet
shouting now hit parade you'll be in the
castle not for long moving out the way
taking all the walls down like a hundred
volts when i charge fully battering rap
and a catapult they'd be struggling
they'd be dying they be starving but me
and my army we charging
a smart thing you can get a general on
the lead got the catapult we leaving
all the lead in the season your turn
[Music]
yes i see locked down [ __ ] two weeks
quarantined
in walter reed like the press right now
quarantined successful in this town so
the colvin cases they will relax this on
your lungs it's a type of repertory
attack
but we're coming back out of there
praise be the queen just have to say
that
moving from quarantine to my three guys
here at the end of the row
we be getting first one from a lovely
trio
yeah let me take a sip whether it's
green or yellow passing on my lips
though the yellow one
cat piss that be the flavor chartreuse
in the last word for later maybe
an aviation if you got the food violet
when it comes to cocktails how good can
you get
made by monks in the french region
chartreuse in your brain
for some reason billboard top 100 i can
chart you
yellow sweater like the chartreuse ask
you what you're asking us to do
cast an eye like the mask though white
and cream peach tie-dye
coming up we got two more to go
add it into the flow dwayne the rock
johnson
hard light metal but came out and
supported by them people say
pebble you are no longer a rock from
hawaii
he was in moana all the people cry he's
so strong
and really good looking would turn me
gay that's what the rock's cooking sorry
why
filming on the camera there last one
from the last with the auburn hair
what's he gonna be i like the camera and
you see
when you're in france in gay paree i
take a chance at once i'd be ordering
croissants it's hard an
american a word to pronounce you might
look at me
slightly ascant if i say it in french
because that's not croissant
[Applause]
thank you have a little rummage get
something ready um let's do this
beat drops then i go green with a little
crescent poblano feeling very spicy yeah
we need succeed when you slice it roast
with the seeds coming from mexico or
maybe new
i don't even know larger chili whipping
it out like a big guy
oh yeah put out your eye any more things
in there we said
got a different color from green then
red that's green and golden red then
stop
no problem oh yeah kick back like a
skeleton there in the chair with a jar
tiny little thing called tomato feed to
your kids
if you want the flavor get heritage what
the heck is this let me see
will not touch him might agree you say
wax why the [ __ ] would you
have that here unless your trucks on
your skateboard near waxing
won't touch it without asking don't want
that contact want that handle get that
wax with a wick for a candle yeah
the man with the charm got their sock in
his nice cold hard
showing the soul and we see is dirty
getting the weave on there kind of 30
months old
probably you've got a nice little mask
and it's good to see that you've got a
variety still something to think
got in the orange and white and then
pink also wax and i thought it was
quartz everybody get with the
skateboards let me look at your little
wrists with the turquoise coming over
there and your name i i'm not annoyed
kate is your name that's k-a-t-e i hope
that we all agree
not a friendship bracelet from your
friend i'm a guy driving [ __ ] around the
bend
yeah jumping out the waves like the
emotion see a little shark saying
protect our ocean he got the shades
and their inhabitants and it's written
like straight lines having it
what's been all that i can't even see
don't want to touch that chest no please
touching the nipples will be
inappropriate any more things that you
get you've got a bike on the bag and
it's going well on the other side logo
says chanel
maybe now wait that's on your necklace
if i'm on a bike then i'm winning that
race
like queen fat bottom girls if you don't
know the song that's the worst in the
world
lasting on the top of you it's off the
top of my dome but salty crew
see all the sharks in the sea i assume
sailing by when i'm old they're in the
school
getting the shark and the fin for the
tuna make it to soup and i wish i'd done
sooner casting the net and i'm casting
the lime salty crew right on the top of
your mind
there we go yeah that's the end of the
wrap with the face mask covered with the
[Music]
map
thank you i'm glad you liked it i'm
going to drop a beat give me give me a
first word to go on whoever's got the
first word
the debut the first word you said that's
the answer to the question
the chicken or the egg cause it came
first that's the question is clever
i see a little chicken with the [ __ ] and
it's feathers in the yard pecking around
for the corn
rooster crowing early in the morn to
warn saying gotta wake it up let me get
the vault if you're on the flow tiller
then you're chilling on the boat in the
caribbean
or maybe tahiti i got my own yacht
not a dinghy rubber over ocean like i'm
floating
in the motion i see it causing up
commotion need a little chocolate chip
need a little bit of wheat need a bit of
egg that's a tasty snack to eat let me
get a little cookie and i might risk it
in britain we don't say that we say
biscuit i know over here that's a
different type of thing
whip it out like a little bit of rope
that stings let me drop it in the ring
so it's gonna ring ah a donut that's the
whole thing
that's a little homonym that's a little
pun if i get a little donut then it's
yummy and my tongue want a bit of
powdered sugar
want a bit of glazing love the doughnuts
from over there
so amazing keep the words flowing as we
go and take a licking we'd be going back
to man who'd be spitting about the
chickens that is okay you'll be smitten
i'm so glad you asked stopping all the
spread of the kobe with the mask i'd be
taking you to task if you're not wearing
one
if you've got a cough better put one on
and in areas like taiwan
and south korea they always had the mass
dangling from around their ears but
more recent over here now we feel i keep
the [ __ ] rolling like limbistic or a
wheel
lit biscuit i meant limp biscuit back to
the cookie if i see your wheel
invent it like i'm the first guy to
invent the 360.
nice little shape one edge that's free
sleep
keep it going what was it you asked okay
i thought you said
my ex's ass that was a weird thing now
it's par for the course
pumping out the gas from my mouth like
an exhaust get a little muffler
keep it quiet because the motor bikes
when they ride not silent they're so
loud pumping out the back of gasoline
one last one from the team and a dream
of a snow cat peak
burst like a fountain call me m and
hillary i'm clambering the mountain i'm
right up the top of k2 and i say 2.
oh you guys they're wrapped till my face
is blue
so collecting comics spartan mascot
speech
therapist dairy and gluten free and loud
dogs
okay this is freestyle all made up not
written not rehearsed
let's uh let's do this
[Music]
rhyming with no script edger seat scary
the only thing you gotta skip be the
dairy
of course you get a soup ah a crouton i
can't consume that wine it contains
gluten
i'm shooting the way to shooting all the
chef if you're bringing me the cheese
then i'm asking you the test did you
listen what i ordered
i don't want these produce from the cow
it scares me
also makes my tummy run also makes my
celiac attack you can get the tummy
cancer and you can't flip it back
unless they get a cure maybe you can try
and help
if i see a tiny tike a tiny little whelp
coming in
i say yo what's up sir he says i've got
a problem you know that i stutter you
can make sure
he can help and improve resist all the
stutter speech therapists move like
biden on the podium when he's in debate
i know the letter
b and letter d is the one he hates which
is inconvenient because it's in his name
what's your favorite superhero one that
spits flames human flame fantastic four
now we don't need these guys see
the worst losers screw all of the dc i
might befringer if i set a new avengers
going off to marvel i'll be gathering
november when it's comic-con time
getting all the mint condition put a
little plastic slip on i never miss them
and if i had detected comics episode one
you know i got the money that's an ebay
auction getting all of that my pockets
no longer
spartan and empty yes you know we're
starting to go to michigan state i think
that's what you said
a spartan warrior you put the mascot on
your head walking around upon the field
like hip hip hooray
cheer for the spartans every day we're
gonna strike hard
light lightning and thunder the only
thing i know about sparta from 300
that's the movie from a comic book
adapted for the big screen
what are the colors of the state white
and green also the nigerian flag but i
assume you're not from there
there we go a freestyle wrap for the
lady with bun hair
thank you thank you guys thank you i'm
glad you liked it it's a fun thing to do
i feel the people the back of the line
are very confused now
we'll we'll come up we'll come and wrap
for you guys the terrible twos bicycles
university of arizona
and being in the us but being from the
uk
a freestyle for the ladies already seen
this i'm firing up like the weather in
phoenix
living there in the past that's you had
your home there that's the university
the state of arizona
never visited i'm inquisitive to do so
if i travel south from here
and you do bro reach there soon off to
the
uni you can study all the things screw
soon each state university of new york
it's much colder over there if you walk
the walk let me ask you
why you're throwing tantrums there's no
answer they're just 24 months old
pull your pants up annoying child throw
in all the wobblers
terrible twos it'd be annoying the
toddler's walking around saying mom
i need a wee but then he already did
himself naturally
they gotta learn to ride a bike at that
age but they fall off no stabilizers
feeling rage what's the problem with the
kids
why they throw these all the hormones
when they chew they tease on their mouth
need to get their little tooth growing
through
moving from a country which begins with
the you to another one
both of them are united i've got a visa
i was totally invited don't throw me out
please don't call ice improvements from
the uk the weather is nice and if you
get a serving of food you can eat it
twice
leftovers more calories advise anybody
in the uk
to visit over here it's great even
though you've got to be older to drink
beer
and that's the real problem unless you
got the id but i can get that yeah
please remind
me was there any more things that we
needed to do
now we nailed that stuff like the sprig
on a stew get them in that's the top
that's the wrap that you heard so many
lenses on your phone there we go
that serves there you go
oh thank you very much guys this is a
wrap about
too many ineffective rules people don't
care about the environment or other
people college is too expensive
zoom and what's that one any others or
without all them
too many rules great i'm going to drop b
it's going to be a real aggro wrap we're
going to get up in the face of that
let's do it
sit down i'm spitting to falls i'm
saying got to redact it reducing the
rules what's the problem
so many rules and we got them i need to
rewind up like cotton on a reel
let me tell you how i feel i'm looking
over there see all the trees on the hill
all of them cutting down going higher
coming down all the forest with forest
fires like what
need to stop the global warming let me
sound out like greta tumba warning from
sweden yeah she has spurges
she coming over here yeah this world
should be like what why am i in this
room
trying to go study but i gotta be zoomed
everyone there with the internet
connection need a little problem let me
guess election a better internet
getting that cable teacher on there he
unstable shouting at me and i'm raising
my hand i'd be like please guy
don't understand i'm in college gotta be
confined to my place
can't get close in anybody's face can't
go bars well technically
probably underage not 23 or 21 but there
we go i encounter people all over the
world
they're like what tell you man let me
spit the truth i don't give a damn like
what
where's your empathy it should be in you
it's meant to be
i'm bringing the politeness sent for me
coming from britain light overseas
last one that we needed to do give me
the word i'm reminding of you
any other thing that you want to throw
in you can throw one word in the wrap
i'm spitting just anything now
shout out please yeah
i do adore these let me kick off
righteous fury f-u-r-i having that fun
furious cutting tits off like amazon's
when i'm over there
yeah we assuming furiously in my breast
i'm brewing
need to go out get a little meditation
get the anger management situation
please everybody calm down there we go
the rap spit
in this town thanks for watching please
do like and subscribe and check out
another one of my freestyle videos
thank you you got me really angry
that's what happens
revolution